Female orgasms seems to be so mysterious they’ve
been the subject of studies for ages.
Can we just agree that at the end of the day
they’re all just awesome?
Hello everyone, Amy here for DNews.
Sexually speaking, women tend to be bit more
complicated than men.
Female arousal is heavily dependent on location,
comfort, stress, and even more nebulous factors
like relationship with a partner and contextual
life.
And many women still don’t know exactly
what gets them off.
Is it direct clitoral stimulation?
Friction from intercourse?
A mixture of both?
In order to understand a female orgasm, it
helps to know the parts involved.
First off, the part you can see on the outside
is not the vagina.
It’s actually called the the vulva; the
vagina is the canal inside the vulva.
And then there’s the clitoris.
Most of us think of the clitoris as a small
organ typically covered by a hood but it’s
actually so, so much more.
The clitoris the metaphorical tip of the iceberg,
the iceberg in this case being a system of
nerves and muscles called the clitorourethrovaginal
complex or CUV that surrounds the vagina and
the urethra.
Since there is an external and internal portion
of this CUV complex, there are two types of
orgasms women can experience: clitoral and
vaginal.
The difference is just the means by which
these nerves are stimulated; for clitoral
orgasms it’s the external part of the clitoris
that is being stimulated.
For a vaginal orgasm it’s nerves inside
the vagina that are being stimulated.
Most women reach climax sooner from clitoral
stimulation since this tiny external portion
has more nerve endings than any other human
body part, male or female, but at the end
of the day it’s all the same bundle of nerves
and muscles.
It’s not entirely surprising that not everyone
understands this distinction.
The clitoris wasn’t even scientifically
‘discovered’ until the 1500’s, and for
centuries the body part was pretty much ignored.
This was partially because of the taboo surrounding
female sexuality, but also scientists didn’t
really see the value in having a clitoris,
or a female orgasm at all.
It’s an orgasm that doesn’t emit sperm
so doesn’t further the human race.
So, they thought, what’s the point of having
or studying the female orgasm?
In fact, the idea that a women could have
different types of orgasms didn’t arise
until the early 1900’s.
Famed Psychiatrist Sigmund Freud argued that
clitoral orgasms are inferior to vaginal orgasms
because women can only fully realize their
mature sexuality from a having intercourse
with a man.
Today we know that this is totally ridiculous,
but still many women say clitoral and vaginal
orgasms feel different, so why?
And how?
Well it may have something to do with blood
flow.
In a 2014 study, scientists observed women
during clitoral and vaginal stimulation using
ultrasounds.
The researchers found that while clitoral
orgasms altered blood flow in the exterior
clitoris, vaginal orgasms affected blood flow
in the entire clitoral network, the CUV.
These differences in blood flow were correlated
to the change in sensation.
But, vaginal or clitoral -- even male or female!
-- all orgasms have largely the same effect
on the body and brain.
Orgasms occur when the muscles that were tightened
during arousal finally relax.
This happens through a series of rhythmic
contractions.
The feeling of ecstasy, bliss and sometimes
a rush of emotion come from a release of hormones
like dopamine oxytocin and prolactin in your
brain.
And scientists say this has major health benefits.
Orgasms are said to reduce stress, improve
sleep and lower blood pressure.
So we should stop pigeonholing orgasms into
just vaginal or clitoral and instead focus
on the feelings they give us.
In the end, they’re all pretty great!
So that's all about good sex.
But what about when sex goes horribly, horribly
wrong?
You can check out the latest episode and all
episodes of Sex Sent Me To The ER on the Discovery
Life Go app.
Check out the link below or download it from
your app store.
And speaking of good sex...
Could sex be so good that it actually kills
you?
Jackie has the answer to the odd question
of whether or not sex can kill your grandfather
in this video right here.
This happens because the male body responds
to cardio-vascular stress by increasing vascular
resistance, which is the force that opposes
blood flow.
This can lead to an uptick in blood pressure.
Got any more questions about orgasms or sex
in general?
Let us know in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe right here for a new episode
of DNews every single day of the week.